so my book is coming out today my book
is out today my book is out today I've
come to Waterstones in Piccadilly just
to I mean just to see it more than
anything else just to know that it was
really happening that I hadn't been you
know taken for a ride but though it
seems as though I did write a book and
it is in stores you can buy it if you
would like to I never really thought
that I would write a book in my life it
was just something that I never really
thought that I was gonna be capable of
so I didn't really even consider it as
an option for me and I think that some
people would see that as a bad thing
usually the way it works the kind of
narrative that we're taught is that you
have a dream you aspire to it you reach
it and you feel great safe or the kind
of people who you know should be writing
books are the people who have a dream to
write a book for me personally though
you know it's one thing to have a dream
and it's another thing to have that
dream be the thing you're actually
supposed to do for a few years now I've
been kind of honing in on being a writer
director of fill that has been my dream
that's been my aspiration and you know
I've had a good go at it I've enjoyed it
I've gotten a lot out of it so what
happened was that when I was approached
to see if I would be interested in
writing a book I thought well that's not
that's not my dream and you know I
almost considered not doing it at all
but for whatever reason I thought let's
take this opportunity you know let's see
where this might end up and what I have
discovered through this whole process is
that I absolutely love writing I think
that it as a creative this you is
something that just fits so much better
with me like Who I am now than anything
else I've done in the past it's
something that I will you know leave up
to the people reading the book to decide
whether or not they think I'm good at it
but I think it was just very surprising
to me to try and do something that I had
never really considered fully before I
just kind of gave it a go and then to
find out actually I think this is what I
want to do with my life
not that I want to kind of distance
myself from doing filmmaking I just
think I want to focus more on screen
right now but I also you know I want to
write more books like I've started
ideas for lots of different stuff I want
to write not just science stuff
basically what I'm trying to say is I
think it's okay for you to say you know
I have a dream I aspire to it but I will
happily change the course that I'm
taking based on what opportunities arise
and what I think fits with Who I am
today and for who I am today want to be
a writer which is convenient because I
just just wrote a book didn't I help
doesn't it so yeah if it does interest
you I would encourage you to pick up a
copy if you're interested in getting a
signed copy of the book I am going on
this tour around the UK all of the dates
and things be in the description I'm
also just about to go to New York to do
an event there and yeah it would be
lovely to see you and you know just find
out what you think about the book
because I'm ready for this to be a real
thing that exists in the world now this
whole process has just been a journey of
understanding for me
wow that not try at all should really
work on that if I want to be a writer
but it is a journey you know it is and
I'm excited to see where it goes thank
you again for watching in for all of
your support and I'll see you again soon
bye bye I'll see you on tour yeah you've
just had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool thank you very much
for watching do check out my previous
video where I talked about the making of
the book how the whole thing came
together and you know what else can I
say really just just thank you I mean I
wouldn't have had the opportunity to do
this if it wasn't for your continued to
the poor you know not everyone gets the
opportunity to just be like I don't know
what I want to do I guess I'll write a
book because that's there and then oh I
guess this is what I want to do of my
life like who gets to do that I get to
do that and that's because of you so
yeah thank you foursome
alright that's all bye bye